this bitcoin mining facility in upstate
new york home to thousands of computers
running nearly 24 7.
is just five miles from niagara falls
near one of the largest sources of hydro
electricity in the u.s
at the facility workers are attempting
to build a more sustainable way to mine
for bitcoin a process that has generated
a lot of criticism for the amount of
energy it consumes recent data estimates
that globally it consumes over a hundred
terawatt hours of electricity annually
or more than the country of finland
in 2018 one study estimated that in less
than 30 years emissions from bitcoin
mining alone could push up global
warming above 2 degrees celsius and
recent crackdowns on cryptocurrencies in
china are putting an even bigger
spotlight on the environmental impact of
the industry you have this bitcoin
mining sector that is very hungry for
innovation and technological solutions
bitcoin miners around the world are
making changes that they say will make
the process more sustainable both
environmentally and financially here's a
look at how this transformation is
playing out
the facility in niagara falls is owned
by bit digital and block fusion two
crypto mining companies that are
harnessing the power of water to cut
down on their operations emissions this
place was founded as a coal
factory to power a tire company
and
this was decommissioned and
repurposed into a bitcoin mining
facility not using fossil fuels but
instead using niagara falls and using
that clean source of power to power this
facility
sam tabarra helps run bitdigital a
member of the crypto climate accord
which aims to transition the crypto
industry to net zero greenhouse gas
emissions by 2040. we intend to be 100
renewable way before then we're about
half renewables now and is in the next
few months we'll be dramatically
increasing that percentage according to
tabar this facility which runs largely
on renewable hydropower is almost
entirely carbon neutral the process
starts here at the robert moses niagara
power plant where water from the niagara
river runs through 13 turbines to
produce renewable electricity
this is then transported through high
voltage transmission lines to bit
digital's facility where it powers a
warehouse of mining machines
the computers use bitcoin's proof of
work method which burns huge amounts of
energy
this process is part of how the
cryptocurrency builds its blockchain
which is key to keeping it decentralized
and secure
around the world powerful computers work
simultaneously to guess a complex
sequence of numbers to validate a block
of transactions
the miner whose computer gets there
first is awarded bitcoin this
transaction is recorded on the
blockchain ledger which is essentially a
digital record book
while secure proof of work needs large
amounts of processing power simply
because it requires all of the mining
computers to work on the same puzzle
these
math problems are very complicated and
they'll only increase in difficulty
as more and more miners come into the
system
so there's no debate that it takes a lot
of electricity the debate is
where that source of electricity comes
from the process to unlock new bitcoins
also has limits
right now over 18 and a half million
bitcoins have been mined out of a
maximum 21 million
and the more miners that seek out those
remaining coins the more energy
intensive the process becomes
this is what is driving concern over
electricity consumption in the crypto
industry it is true that it is energy
intensive however
it's all about the sources of energy if
you use clean sources of energy
it's not a problem if you're using dirty
sources
that's a problem while renewable sources
of energy release less co2 into the
atmosphere than fossil fuels experts say
that hydropower facilities can still
have harmful impacts on ecosystems and
biodiversity
bitcoin mining both renewable and
non-renewable also generates electronic
waste an estimated 11.5 kilotons per
year bitdigital also runs a number of
other operations that use renewables
such as this solar-powered mining site
in nebraska other bitcoin miners in the
us are eyeing nuclear power and
countries like iceland are home to
operations using geothermal energy tabar
says that along with his company's
transition to renewables bit digital is
ramping up operations in north america
partly a reaction to their recent
regulatory crackdowns in china for years
the company like many other crypto
miners ran part of its business out of
china but just months ago the country
effectively banned bitcoin mining which
has driven many in the industry to
rapidly move operations to other
countries like the u.s canada and
kazakhstan it's been a great thing for
the united states because
all this innovation in the power sector
is happening as a result of this at this
ban the focus on finding renewable
sources of power and creating
technological solutions to create
further efficiencies for tabar
transitioning the crypto industry to
renewable energy isn't just for the good
of the environment it also has financial
benefits i don't think investors are
keen to invest in bitcoin mining
companies that are not looking at
cleaner sources of power
that is not the right investment to make
you want to be profitable but we don't
want to destroy the earth while we're at
it while critics remain skeptical of the
crypto industry's energy demands the
push for a more sustainable mining
future continues to pick up steam
[Music]
you